patrick dils restera en prison
hier soir les jurés de la cour d'assises
de reims n'ont pas suivi l'intimé
conviction de l'avocat général qui
réclamait l'acquittement
le jeune homme a donc été condamné à 25
ans de réclusion criminelle
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
judiciaire qu'un procès en révision
conclu une seconde fois à la culpabilité
stéphanie perez et salah à granby tout y
est laisser penser que patrick dils e
sortirai libre de la cour d'assises de
reims mais dans la soirée c'est dans un
fourgon de police et en direction de la
prison qu'il a quitté le tribunal
toujours impassible sa mère son frère
ses avocats sont abasourdis contre toute
attente et surtout contre le
réquisitoire de l'avocat général
le jury populaire confirme sa
culpabilité dans les meurtres de cyril
et d'alexandre en 86 6 longues heures de
délibéré huit voix sur douze pour le
condamné à 25 ans de prison
expliquez moi
cette décision je comprends pas perdre
je comprends pas alors nous avons 4
comprennent pas non plus
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé la froideur la
passivité de patrick dils l'expliquent
peut-être selon les avocats des familles
des deux victimes
il fallait avoir peut-être une autre
attitude que celle qu'il a eue et
peut-être aussi que cette attitude qu'il
a eu pendant ces derniers temps depuis
la requête en révision en clamant
l'innocence qui n'a pas réussi à
démontrer qui n'a pas qu'il ne ressort
pas véritablement du dossier eh bien
peut-être que cette attitude là explique
les 25 ans
prononcé pour les familles des petits
garçons qui écartaient l'hypothèse
francis heaulme le soulagement après une
journée lourde d'incertitudes mais ils
font sur qui date qu'elle avait tous les
petits garçons
c'était pas de la fantaisie on avait un
dossier qu'il parlait on avait des
certitudes on avait dit qu'on avait des
confessions qu'il avait fait perry dont
je vous ai toujours dit qu'on pouvait
pas inventé patrick dils et ses avocats
sont maintenant confrontés à un choix
difficile faire appel et défendra si son
honneur ou bénéficier bientôt d'une
libération conditionnelle puisqu'il a
déjà passé 14 ans en prison si je crois
qu'il pourra peut-être quand même
privilégié la voile la de la liberté
liberté conditionnelle tout en
poursuivant une action de révision je
comptais les pensées concession finira
par avouer ce crime et alors là c'est
moi pas tu as la place des magistrats
pendant ces neuf jours d'un huis clos
hors norme
il n'aura été question que d'un team
conviction celle de la défense et de
l'avocat général contre celle de
l'accusation et finalement des jurés un
procès énigmatique à l'image de la
personnalité de l'accusé